brooklyn purchased three pounds of pasta
and 12 ounces of cheese to make macaroni
and cheese
what is the total weight in ounces
total weight in ounces of the pasta and
cheese combined
so they give us the weight of the pasta
in pounds and they give us the weight of
the cheese in ounces and we want to add
the total weight but they have to all be
in ounces so let's first let's first
convert these three pounds of pasta into
a certain amount of ounces of ounce of
pasta so we already know that one pound
is equal to 16 ounces they tell us that
so what would three pounds be so
if i had three pounds
how many ounces would that be and i
encourage you to pause the video and
think about it
let's see if you're having three times
the pounds
you're also going to have three times
the ounces so if one pound is 16 ounces
if you have three times as many pounds
you're gonna have three times as many
ounces so 16 times three is 48
48 ounces
so brooklyn the three pounds of pasta
that she purchased that can also be
viewed as 48 ounces
48 ounces
of pasta so she has 48 ounces of pasta
and 12 ounces of cheese so what is the
total weight in ounces of them combined
what's going to be 48
ounces
48 ounces
plus the 12 ounces of cheese 48 ounces
of pasta plus 12 ounces of cheese give
us a total of 60 ounces of pasta and
cheese
combined let's do another example with
other units
so we are told
david is making a wall out of bricks
each brick is two-thirds of a foot long
there are 20 bricks lined up end-to-end
to make the wall
what is the total length of the wall in
inches we got to keep pay attention to
the units so they give us the length of
each brick in feet
so
we know
that each brick here let me draw a brick
the length here is two thirds of a foot
two-thirds of a foot so what would this
length be in inches
well once again we can look at the
conversion between foot and inches if i
go from one foot to two-thirds of a foot
well i've multiplied by two-thirds so if
one foot is 12 inches and if i want to
know how many inches two-thirds inches
or two-thirds of a foot is in inches
well i would multiply by two-thirds
again
in either case you could view this as
multiplying both sides of this
conversion by two-thirds
and so two-thirds of a foot is going to
be two-thirds times twelve inches and so
twelve
times two over 3 that would be 24 over 3
so this is going to be equal to 24 over
inches i'll just write
i n for short right over here 24 over
three which is equal to eight inches
so each brick is either you could either
view it as two-thirds of a foot long or
you could view it as eight inches
eight inches long
and there are twenty bricks lined up end
to end to make the wall so what is the
total length of the wall in inches well
it's going to be eight brick each brick
is eight inches times twenty
times twenty
and eight times two is sixteen so eight
times twenty is one hundred 160
inches
let's do one more of these and this time
let's deal with some volume
so this says blanca buys two gallons of
green paint
she uses five quarts to paint her front
porch and
0.5 quarts to paint the front porch
swing
how many quarts of paint does blanca
have left
so we're given the original amount in
gallons but we want to know how many
quarts she has left so let's convert the
amount she originally has into quarts so
we they tell us one gallon is equal to
four quarts
so two gallons
two gallons is going to be equal to
two
gallons is going to be twice as many
quarts it's going to be eight
quarts
so that's what she starts with and one
way to think about this i just took this
conversion well if i'm going to have
twice as many gallons then i'm going to
have twice as many quarts if i want to
express that volume in quarts so one way
of thinking about she starts with 8
quarts she starts with 8 quarts
eight
quarts she uses five quarts to plate to
paint her front porch so minus five
quarts on the front porch
is what she used and she used point five
quarts to paint the port swing so minus
0.5
quarts
that looks like a g
0.5 quarts well what is that going to be
well 8 minus 5 is 3
minus 0.5 is 2.5
so she is going to be left with 2.5
quarts
and we have answered the question in
terms of the units they care about in
terms of quartz